welcome back to piersburg and uncensored
rafa nadal says wimbledon's ban on
russian players of wimbledon is unfair
or sergey stazkovsky retired from tennis
in january he's now taking up arms to
protect his homeland in ukraine he took
to twitter to say
rafa nadal we competed together we
played each other on tour please tell me
how it's unfair oh it's fair that
ukrainian players cannot return home how
is it fair the ukrainian kids cannot
play tennis how is it fair that
ukrainians are dying and sergey joins me
and now along with legend and nine-time
wimbledon winner martinez welcome to
both of you so again let me start with
you there was a powerful tweet
and there's no doubt when you read that
tweet
and you think about someone like
yourself who played tennis competitively
for ukraine for many years and has now
gone back and has now joined the battle
against putin and and his genocidal
rampage there's no doubt everybody i'm
sure will feel huge empathy with you the
question
becomes i guess
that where where do you take the
argument if individuals
rather than
nations rather than teams for example if
individuals get punished for the for the
behavior of their leaders
then you could end up with a lot of
people getting banned year in year out
for all sorts of reasons
surely they can but unfortunately uh the
regime in russia created a delusional
reality for russians
and the top athletes they have that
reach they have that uh audition for
their fans and they could tell them
what's really going on
and honestly if the russian players and
bear ocean players would come out and
say publicly they condemned the invasion
that they would really say they're
against the war
there'll be something you know everybody
would then consider about banning but
they're staying silent uh saying no war
means if ukraine will stop shooting the
war would be over but it's not true if
ukraine stops shooting there'll be no
more ukraine and normal ukrainians in it
so the question here is it's not about
whether it is good to ban somebody or
not it's a question whether it's normal
to stay neutral when your country is
killing innocent people okay well
martina it's obviously that's not normal
obviously it's disgusting i think we all
agree with that but it's really about i
guess the precedent that's being set
here and i raised the point earlier at
the top of the show that if you had the
same kind of logic for example you know
after the vietnam war after the uh
what many you think was the illegal
invasion of iraq for example then a lot
of american stars would be banned from
tournaments that they ended up winning
what is your view about this
well first i want to say sergey
bravo to you uh my head is off uh i you
are just so brave to be doing what
you're doing truly uh unbelievable
as for the players as you say it could
be a slippery slope i
because what what is the option for the
russian and belarusian players uh if
they support the war i mean i'd say if
they support uh poutine obviously
openly they should not be allowed to
play but if they go against it what does
that have what happens to them what
happens to their families etc they would
literally be forced to defect
uh in order to play tennis and i think
you're making a very unfair situation
obviously horrible situation in ukraine
you're making it worse by doing this i
think the players who did not support
putin who actually have spoken out
against the war like probably chinkova
has openly spoke about it i think rublev
wrote not no to war on the on the camera
after a match
it's such a fine line to walk if you're
from those countries and there is no
good way out of it um so my heart goes
out to everybody involved in this but if
the only option is for these players to
leave their country so they can play
tennis
i think that's that's unfair as well so
gay i mean the president i would i would
say immediately this brings to mind is
saudi arabia's war mongering in yemen
for example hasn't led to a ban on saudi
competitors for example at the olympics
uh it hasn't stopped them hosting a
formula one grand prix race
so there's a lot of hypocrisy here isn't
there about the way that we
we view conflicts around the world and
how we punish people
surely there is but let's say saudi
arabia doesn't possess any nuclear
weapons and saudi arabian
kings do not
europe with airstrikes saying that the
missile will land in london within 200
seconds it's going to land in berlin in
160 seconds on a mainstream tv with your
anchors saying these words and lines
so it's pretty different situation i
would say
when you're preparing your nation which
is russia to basically say that there's
no world without russia in it so they
are preparing the nation if they are
going to lose the war in ukraine that
they are ready to end the world
is that something everybody should
consider
[Music]
i mean i i've got to be honest with you
i i think martina it's a very
complicated issue i actually thought
long and hard over the last day or so
about what i thought about this once i
heard about this band from wimbledon i
understand that wimbledon for example
they're really doing it at the behest of
the british government and the heavy
sanctions they brought in they're sort
of taking their lead from the government
um which some people might think is is a
bit cowardly of them to stand behind the
government but i can understand them
taking the lead in that way and they
wanted to avoid uh it's been reported
the potential spectacle of the men's
tournament being won by a russian
competitor and and for example the
duchess of cambridge
who's the patron of wimbledon tennis
presenting him with an award of giving
putin a massive propaganda prize i mean
this is the the problem isn't it if you
do allow them to compete and they win
putin gets his moment on the world stage
absolutely and that's why we should not
have been rewarding these horrible
countries with international
competitions whether it's the olympics
in china the world cup in qatar world
cup in russia et cetera saudi arabia
having the as you said the f1 races so
it legitimizes these uh these uh
governments and that that's not right on
the other hand tennis is a very
individual sport but it's like it's a
norman situation i know if i was living
in russia right now i would probably be
moving my family out as are many people
that can leave the country because it's
just such a disaster and what they're
doing is so so wrong but it is just
sad that it would have to come to that
but i think if i were if i were living
there i would probably be doing that but
uh yeah there's no way of winning this
one way or the other and the loss of
life and destruction and it's just
unimaginable but i don't know if banning
players from playing tennis is helpful
one way or the other sergey i want to
end with you uh because you've gone back
you've retired earlier this year you're
now you've joined the struggle what is
life like for you in ukraine
in ukraine kiev is getting better first
two weeks for brutal honestly now the
key of going back to the melody because
there's no other way but in general uh
until the 9th of may i think it's going
to be the main time where we'll see
what's going to happen because russia is
planning to do a full scale
i don't know colin arms they would say i
don't know how it's called in english
and then
unfortunately for many of us who have
been put back into research most likely
we have to go back to active duty so
the next two weeks are going to be
crucial and we just hope that the world
will stay at one piece that it is well
we wish you all the very best so good to
you and to your family and indeed to all
ukrainians